Hello
Freak bitches.
There was two guys that were talking about your podcast.
It was fucking hilarious.
They were talking about Lee Lee Saya and they were like,
what Joey has done to that poor guy.
And he's like,
every time he sees him,
he's forcing them to eat mushrooms.
He's got to take acid.
He's giving him pot.
He's given him edibles.
He's lied to him about the dosage
lead.
Loves it.
He loves it.
He does.
He's just did the,
we did that liquid acid with the ice cube with the sugar cubes.
Jesus Christ.
But two weeks ago we did it two nights in a row.
Was hilarious on the show.
He did it.
Yeah.
And then he called me the next day.
He's like,
that was fun.
He goes,
I went to cvs at four in the morning if he wasn't like that before he met you
though.
No,
but he's having a great,
you turn that kid into a freak.
He's not a freak man.
I turned them into a functioning savage,
but I love him like a high level with all my heart because he makes me,
he makes me laugh so much.
Joe,
like he just,
you know,
I'm 54 it's 28 he's half my age.
Right.
You know,
I see life from his perspective,
you know,
and I'm like,
Geez,
these guys get along together.
Great.
It's like a great dynamic.
The two of you together,
it works really well.
Oh,
I love,
I don't see him too much during the week,
so I keep the relationship fresh.
We talk all the time.
I torment the mall.
The other day I called him,
I go,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
Because what are you talking about?
God,
he just got a letter from the state.
Why is your fucking phone pat?
Hmm?
I torment for them for 20 minutes about his phone,
man.
Why?
By bound feed that.
I go,
do you work for the CIA?
They made you come over and take my acid so you can report back to them.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Ah,
that's it.
Don't worry about it must have been a mistake.
And the guy got me the liquid acid,
right?
I called him and I said,
listen,
I got a liquid asset.
He's like,
you can hear him getting anxiety on the phone.
He goes,
oh no,
you were a little bit,
and then he goes,
how are we going to do it?
I said,
so we're going to get sugar cubes and put the acid on it,
but I called them back like a day later that I didn't have no acid and I had no
sugar cubes.
I just made it up.
I go,
listen,
I just put the acid on the cube of sugar cubes.
I put them in a Tupperware and I put a lid on it and I left him.
When I came back to Lynn had blown up,
so whenever is of that acid is going to be really fucking strong.
I go,
I put aluminum foil over.
It would hold so it could breathe so the acid won't fucking go into all my God.
I had them go for three weeks.
I go to Cleveland.
Guess what?
Some guy comes up to me,
gives me a two basket.
This is,
this is the pharmaceutical grade shit.
This will kill Gaddafi.
The home.
I go home,
we put drops on each ice cube.
I need sugar cube.
Oh my fucking God.
Yeah.
But see again,
that's why I quit everything because my tolerance is too hot.
Back in the day,
I could do two drops,
Ibi for 12 hours,
seeing things.
UNICORNS.
I seen something for like two hours,
but you knows what,
how strong it really was to,
and you're getting it from Cleveland.
Yeah.
Got To get it from like northern California.
Oh,
no,
no.
But then I lost,
I lost the 10 sheet from a guy in England.
A Guy in England gave me some stuff.
Pink Floyd acid.
This the same one that Syd Barrett took when he quit pink Floyd.
So I took that.
I save that.
So now I'm going to get the liquid acid.
I'm going to put it on the blotter from pink Floyd and we're going to go deep.
I'm just saving that one for a good guest.
Yeah.